i haven't dead lost position sometimes
the computer says plus five for the
opponent but he still looks super calm
this time no he's shaking his head and
okay he brings his bishop oh no there we
go i mean it's just expected because of
the clock because he's lost control on
the position and that's when blunders
happened they don't just occur out of
nothing
most of the time and okay here we see
stockfish the computer suggestions the
top two moves which give black a
significant advantage
they're also the most obvious moves in
the position
sometimes that's not the case but here
black has a choice the black rook in the
center is attacked by white's bishop you
can just sidestep and capture a pawn
magnus does this you could have captured
the other pawn as well on the left side
that would have been strong too but uh
yeah it's looking very good for magnus
right now he's a pawn up and white's
struggling to create counter threats uh
any compensation here
okay the white bishop steps back that is
a bad sign for duda
and uh okay magnus now
can he continue being greedy
if the black